you're not gonna take if if we can't
you're not gonna take my pain away right
the Jewish people say it's the Holocaust
this happened and you can't say anything
about it we can't take their pain away
No One's Gonna denounce the fact that
they tried to lock me up that's what
because every time I'm just holding
stride and it's like I didn't I thought
I was more Malcolm X but I find out I'm
more MLK because as I'm getting hoes
down every day by the press and
financially I'm just standing there and
when when I found out that they tried to
put me in jail it was like a dog was
biting my arm and I I I almost shed a
tear almost but I still walked and
stride through it yeah I think I think
they've been extremely unfair to you who
was they though we can't tell you they
is can't press I'm not using the I don't
use the word as the way I guess you guys
use I'm talking it is them though isn't
it I mean because because when you think
about it consider it
what do I mean like uh uh okay so how
about
are you leaving
are you afraid of the press
he's on
I'll say it right now
um
you got I I you guys want to bring that
stuff up
yeah
you think yay is going to come in here
and say Here's my opinion here's my
suffering I'm gonna say I hear you and
then he's gonna say and it was Jewish
people and I'm gonna be like okay but
don't you consider so I'm not gonna do
this I refuse make sure he's cool all
right go for it Luke and I love a
conversation so uh I can't say I'm
surprised what what what what what what
do I even do other than ask him please
elaborate on this are you referring to
individuals are you quite literally
blaming an entire group of people for
the fact that powerful individuals are
causing you harm I I really wanted to
ask Nick about his thoughts about MLK
because I know they contradict uh his
comments about that but but again these
are mass generalizations that don't
really help anyone in my perspective
they just kind of sound like their
opposition they sound what they're kind
of going against the woke mob that's
always saying white men white men are
responsible for everything when I see
people just use generalizations it kind
of cheapens the conversations it
cheapens a dialogue that we could have
here that I was planning to to talk to
yay about specifically bringing up like
hey let's actually talk about this in a
real concise way let's not get emotional
let's not walk out of here let me tell
all you guys outright I said this is
going to be a big issue
before the show obviously people are
going to bring up the questions of
anti-Semitism why don't we talk about
the news I want to hear what happened
with this meeting I want to understand
what yay 24 is and then we can do a
longer conversation about any of that
stuff and yay literally in the first
five minutes says no I want to talk
about a group of people and and point to
them whatever man this you want to know
why look you know you're not going to
sit here and you're going to walk out of
the room you're free to do so man
but literally I said a couple sentences
about I don't think that's fair did I
did I insult the man he seriously can't
handle he can't handle it he also left
during the Pierce Morgan interview he
did but he came back so I again we
should be able to have this conversation
what's up Chris
look man
I wanted to talk to these guys about why
they're meeting with Trump I want to
know what happened with the dinner
because we hear a lot of rumors about it
I want to hear about their 2024 platform
which they were promising which they
were talking about like they're going to
be officially let me let me explain to
everybody you know unfortunate they
walked out fine maybe they'll come back
whatever
this is the biggest challenge with
dealing with identitarianism
I do not believe that the predetermined
factor in someone's worth value or
agenda is based on immutable
characteristics uh Kanye is a black man
he does not represent all black people
there are Jewish individuals who work in
in Banks Dave Chappelle made the joke
about Jewish people in Hollywood and he
said it doesn't mean anything you got a
lot of black people in Ferguson doesn't
mean they run the place the point is me
I'm all about individualism meritocracy
personal responsibility that means an
individual of any background can be
capable of anything more importantly we
have employees here who are Jewish who
spend time in Israel and would probably
agree with a lot of issues that they
would talk about especially as it
pertains to America first you know
bringing jobs back here and securing our
borders but then it's just like every
step of the way it's like bro if you
live in a world where a single group of
people is is haunting you you've lost
you you're you're trapped you're not
going to get out the issue is you can
overcome anything I understand you know
and and I empathize that there are
powerful business interests that are
coming coming Kanye and I will say this
because I wanted to get into the Trump
stuff
when when Kanye mentioned he got
suspended on Twitter
then he gets word that Milo wants to
meet up with him then Milo puts him in
touch with Fuentes my immediate you know
my question is okay my thoughts of
myself
we really want to know about the inner
details of this Trump meeting
I guess it's not going to happen my
question then is don't you think that
you know if if Kanye is going to say
these things and then immediately start
getting involved with Fuentes that only
amplifies the accusations made against
them
but I guess if they genuinely believe
these things that's who they are I was
dying to interrupt I was dying to say a
whole bunch of stuff during his you know
his conversation I respectively you know
didn't I was waiting to counter back but
we didn't even push back at all we
didn't even really say anything uh I'm
crazy out there I mean that come on like
we we should at least have the tough
conversations we should debate what are
these ideas what does he think is going
on and I I don't know but I wish I just
wish people were again like hey you
don't agree with me 100 that's fine
that's okay I'm not gonna run away like
like come on let's let's have this
discussion I don't know conversation I
really wanted to talk about Balenciaga I
really wanted to talk about Harley
pasternik I really wanted to talk about
Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle talked
about you know a lot of the things that
that yay was warning about specifically
with people trying to drug him
specifically with people trying to of
course get him on big Pharma medicines
he was again sent to you know he was
institutionalized a couple years ago
specifically on November 21st 2016 he's
pointing a lot of this blame on on this
Harley Pasternak guy who uh again he's
the one who's training lizzo Elliott
page he was training Brittany Murphy he
trained a lot of controversial figures
and he is connected to a Canadian
military psyops that's like we should
know what else is happening behind the
scenes there what else he knows but
before the show we can't even get that
before the show yay was like this was
funny you know he's like how do I become
president how do you win and I thought
it was a rhetorical question because
like why would I know that question and
he was like hey man I asked you a
question you know what do you think and
I was like oh yeah ballot harvesting
like hands down you go to door-to-door
he but he brought it up when he
mentioned that I said that he would do
well with the black vote I feel like
it's kind of oversimplifying what I said
um what I said was that he's a he's a
celebrity he's a personable character
he's he he appeals to regular people
more so if he knocked on the door and
you said Trump Biden yay they'd be like
yay you know but I but I do think that
he would do uh I I do think he would do
better with with the black vote simply
because there's people who look up to
him because they see they can see
themselves in him now let me let me let
me elaborate that's actually more of a
leftist position this woke position uh
because I don't completely disagree with
every every uh component of what
diversity is I think that it's true that
if you're a little kid growing up in
this country
and you're not white but all you ever
see on billboards and all you ever see
in TV is white people that that means
something that has an effect on you and
that's basically what I'm getting to all
I can really say is this uh bro if if I
can't ask you questions
call me like hey but don't you think
this is like localizing he could have
been like I don't you know I I genuinely
view it this way and I'd have said well
okay I can only ask you the question
you're allowed to believe what you want
to believe
but dude like what did I ask him like
three questions about it and he just got
up and left like he's gonna come here
and just talk and be an uninterrupted
before we started the show he said hey
we're doing this show why don't we do it
every week and I'm like what is this is
this is what is because you can't get
enough on any other shows I'm sorry bro
this is not a show where you come in and
talk by yourself and say whatever you
want and say things that are uh that
that that warrant questioning at the
very least at least for clarification
yeah I mean that question everything
should be uh debated everything should
be you know talked about we shouldn't
stray away from uncomfortable situations
we we decide to take things head on like
we have our particular viewpoints they
have theirs we it's obviously there's a
difference obviously we believe in
different things let's see which idea is
better let's see which idea wins out in
the public sphere let's actually have
that conversation and it's kind of sad
that we can't yeah well I think it's
funny that like we got people in super
chats who are like why didn't you just
let them keep talking can keep talking
but that's not how the show works we cut
each other off all the time I just cut
you off right now I know right this is
this is this is our this is the way we
do this guys I'm sorry man I'm not here
to do a show where we let one like look
we and Milo come on a couple weeks ago
and he mostly just talked and I think
there's there's something interesting
there Milo had been banned for a really
long time and had hadn't spoken out in
years five years yeah he's been on a
whole bunch of podcasts so when we were
talking about bringing them on I said
look man
after after the Kyle Rittenhouse stuff
people were like are you gonna get him
on the show and I'm like I don't want to
chase after a dude who like he's in the
news yeah he goes on Rogan before he
goes on Friedman and then I'm like
that's cool they got those conversations
then we were told we would get Milo
Fuentes and yeah at the same time and we
could talk about this big news because
that's what we do we are a topical news
show with guests we are not Joe Rogan
Experience we're not guest interviews
and so with Milo we had him on and it
turned into something different because
the man's been out of the Limelight for
five years and came back and said Trump
supporters want revenge
so here on this show I don't want to
tell you man yay doesn't have to do
anything he owes me no no favors he
wanted to come on the show but he didn't
want to have a conversation yeah I
didn't disrespect him we were nice to
him you know we we hung out with him uh
uh before the show you know we we tried
to accommodate him the best of our
abilities but he didn't want to
entertain a conversation I can't make
him he doesn't owe me that he can leave
that's his that's his thing you know
appreciate him him trying as best as he
did that's about it that's true I mean
what else can you do right I mean look
you know let me tell you guys some
stories because uh I guess this is the
show now welcome to the Monday night
show it was all hype and then all
nothing
you know I don't like identitarianism I
I've never been a fan of people who've
blamed everyone else for their problems
I remember doing Occupy Wall Street you
had people saying it was the one percent
that was the cause of their problems and
I'm like what are you talking about you
got one percenters here giving you money
you've got rich people down here
supporting Occupy Wall Street providing
funding you've got like George Soros
money going into these non-profits that
are funding you to complain about rich
people
it the problem is is varying agendas the
problem is varying ideologies the
problem is everyone fighting for power
for what they want
in yay's circumstance they're coming
after him they're trying to take away
his stuff they're threatening them with
institutionalization and I understand
all of that it's unfortunate that he's
he's internalized this problem to it is
a it is a specific ethnic and religious
background that's doing it and I'm like
bro it's specific people doing it to you
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
what else to say we can read super chats
well I think Super chats would be
interesting to to spur on this
conversation but we made it 27 minutes
and YouTube didn't take it down you just
got up and left yeah people people don't
understand we took a big risk tonight
like it was my channel it was your
channel especially on the line because
again we're we're hosting conversations
that are tough that are not easy to have
that we need to be ready for that we
need to of course counter ideas just to
let the best idea win so you know it
would take in this risk it's just
unfortunate that they'd play it played
off the way it did again we don't he
doesn't owe us anything uh but it it
this just should have done I I just wish
it would have went a totally different
way but you can't control individuals
and if someone can't handle getting
their their assertions questioned well
why did he get so angry about it I don't
get it I don't understand it it's not
like we were confrontational it's not
like we were rude uh I definitely I I
definitely disagreed with some of the
statements and I was waiting to jump in
just to have that conversation well
here's my thing I don't know who he's
talking about I don't know exactly what
happened yeah and so when he says a
thing happened to me and I'm like but
who did it
what am I supposed to be like you've
gotta I'm sorry man like the idea that
you've got a group of people
of this like
it just doesn't make sense I'm sorry man
it just doesn't there's there's
certainly powerful individuals who are
friends with each other like I said
Bezos billionaire Bill Gates billionaire
Bill Gates going on TED Talks talking
about depopulation you've got uh here's
an example Shane Smith CEO of ice Irish
Canadian Guy multi-billionaire created a
woke media Empire so when we're talking
about censorship and silencing and he
says it's like Jewish or whatever and
I'm like
but you what do you what does that mean
like there's woke entities that are
completely white European dudes antifa's
mostly white European they're not Jewish
guys going around smashing up Windows
this is this is the issue of people
blaming a group of people when the issue
is specific to
something unrelated to their background
I don't know what else man how are you
guys doing
um I don't know I might want to go
downstairs and see if we could get him
back I think it's worth a try I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to talk to him see if I'll
read super chats yeah I'll read super
chats and uh
well that was fun
we're just gonna sit here I guess so
we'll read some super chats because uh
otherwise that's it
you know it is what it is guys we try we
try I mean Luke is right he has left
podcast before and then come back
sometimes it just takes people and it's
a really good lesson takes a minute to
calm down then you can come back after
he needs to explain what he means right
he can't just say it's true and I'm like
what do you mean by The Who referring to
no I'm done I'm believing it's like okay
then I assume you have nothing behind
what you're saying right and here and
I'll tell you what else too because when
early on he said like how do I want to
set ballot harvesting but I gotta say
man if if this like why would someone
vote for this thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time